er herzlich willkommen heute geht es um
tomaten und zwar nicht in die tomaten
die man im beet oder im gewächshaus
anbauen kann sondern um topf thoma
hatten also wenn du im topf oder kübel
auf dem balkon oder auf der terrasse
tomaten anbauen möchte ist dann bist du
hier genau richtig
ich werde dir nämlich jetzt zeigen wie
das funktioniert das ist gar nicht so
einfach
tomaten im topf so anzubauen dass sie
wirklich kräftig werden und richtig
ertrag abwerfen und deswegen teile ich
heute 11 tipps mit dir die deinen
tomaten zu sagen höchstform verhelfen
sollen also los geht's dann mit
[Musik]
ich habe nur mal eins ist es deine
tomaten einen richtig großen topf
brauchen das ist der häufigste fehler
den ich sehe wenn leute tomaten im topf
anbauen dass die einen viel zu kleinen
topf nehmen da haben die tomaten
überhaupt keine chance richtig groß und
fertig zu werden und ganz ganz viele
tomaten zu produzieren also ganz so groß
wie meiner muss der topf nicht sein aber
20 liter sollte der mindestens fassen
damit deine tomaten überhaupt das zeug
haben oder die grundlage haben um
richtig gut zu produzieren nummer zwei
ist das deine tomaten hungrig sind
deswegen brauche ich meine tomaten am
allerliebsten in reinem kompost an den
kann ja im garten selber machen ist
immer noch cooler irgendwie als fertige
tomaten erde zu kaufen das würde aber
natürlich auch gehen und am
allerliebsten verwende ich dafür
verrotteten hühnermist kompost das hat
den grund dass in china misst ganz viel
phosphor und stickstoff enthalten ist
und die tomaten sich darin natürlich
nach umso wohler fühlen weil das sind
zwei sachen auf die wito da stehen ja
damit will ich also die untere hälfte
meines kopfes und dann gebe ich ein bis
zwei hände sand dazu und vermische das
ganze gut das mache ich deswegen damit
das wasser besser abfließen kann damit
die tomaten nicht so nasse füße bekommen
das mögen die nämlich nicht und so habe
ich im unteren teil des topfes dann noch
so ein bisschen eine lockere erde wo was
ein bisschen besser ablaufen kann als im
oberen bereich das hat sich bei uns sehr
gut bewährt das so zu machen
tipp nummer drei ist dass du in jedem
job wirklich nur eine tomatenpflanze
sitzen sollte ist das ist deswegen
wichtig weil die sich sonst gegenseitig
konkurrenz machen und nie so groß und
kräftig werden wie sie eigentlich werden
könnten deswegen das machen auch über
ganz viele leute gerade wenn sie noch so
klein sind dann traut man ihnen ja auch
gar nicht so wie groß die man irgendwann
werden dass sie dann zwei oder sogar
drei tomaten in einen topf pflanzen
das machen wir nicht das kannst du
machen wenn du mauer maurer kübel
verwendest zum tomatenpflanzen da
passten dann schon mal zwei oder sogar
drei automaten in einen kübel aber wenn
du die im topf an baust dann immer nur
eine pflanze protox ganz wichtig ich
habe ja letztens schon mal ein video
über tomaten gemacht da ging es um
freiland tomaten und tomaten die man ins
gewächshaus pflanzt das kann ich euch
gerne noch mal da oben verlinken und da
habe ich euch ja meine geheime dünger
mixtur vorgestellt die kommt jetzt auch
wieder zu
ein satz das ist nun einmal hornspäne
einmal magnesium sulfat und einmal
urgesteins mail zu gleichen anteilen und
die vermisse ich jetzt gut miteinander
und dann gebe ich statt zwei esslöffeln
diesmal drei esslöffel pro pflanze in
den topf und vermische das auch wieder
mit der unteren hälfte die wir schon
gefüllt haben also mit dem kompost so
dass die tomaten gut mit dünner dünger
und allem was sie brauchen versorgt sind
fürs erste man muss dann später schon
auch noch dünnen das erzähle ich euch
auch gleich noch wie das geht aber das
hier ist eine super start wäre also die
sachen kann ich euch wieder in der
infobox verlinken wenn ihr schauen wollt
was ich da benutze und davon gebe ich
jetzt drei esslöffel pro pflanze in den
topf und dann einmal richtig gut
umrühren ja und dann kommen wir zur
nummer fünf jetzt pflanzen wir die
tomaten und dann ist es ganz wichtig
dass ihr die unteren blätter die den
boden berühren ab knipst die tomaten
werden immer ein bisschen tiefer gesetzt
als sie im job stehen so dass sie noch
mehr wurzeln bilden können und noch
fester stehen und da könnt ihr ruhig
ordentlich viel von eurem pflänzchen
abknipsen und ich schön tief in die erde
stecken und alle blätter die dann
hinterher noch den boden berühren auch
einfach ab machen das ist ganz wichtig
weil die pflanzen sehr anfällig sind für
die krautfäule die kommt vom boden auf
die blätter hoch und deswegen sollten
die blätter niemals den boden berühren
wenn ihr euch übrigens fragt welche
sorten wir anbauen kann ich euch auch
gerne ein video hier oben verlinken wo
ich meine fünf allerliebsten
tomatensorten vorstellen es gibt ja 1000
hummer am sollten liegen alle ganz toll
sind und alle ganz unterschiedlich sind
und wenn ihr euch da mal inspirieren
lassen wollt dann klickt gerne da oben
ich werde jetzt in die töpfe die sorte
zucker traube pflanzen eine sehr tolle
cherry tomate die super lecker ist und
die wir immer wieder gerne an bauen die
auch relativ freiland tauglich ist das
heißt selbst wenn es mal ein bisschen
nass wird hier auf der terrasse oder auf
dem balkon
dann macht die nicht gleich schwach
tomaten sind daher sehr empfindlich wir
haben die schon sehr erfolgreich hier am
haus im kübel angebaut oder im topf und
auch schon im freiland in
also eine tolle sorte wenn man die
tomaten auf der terrasse oder auf dem
balkon anbauen recht tipp nummer sechs
ist eine tomaten brauchen irgendeine
form von rang hefe das kann ein ganz
normaler tomaten starb sein es kann aber
auch einen stock sein er sollte lang
genug sein dass die tomaten da lang
daran hoch wachsen können also um die
zwei meter wäre nicht schlecht
jedenfalls längst du dann ganz tief in
deinem kopf damit einen guten stand hat
und auch die pflanze stützen kann
und dann kannst du die pflanze da immer
wieder dran hoch binden also ich mach
dann immer eine lockere schlaufe um den
stil der pflanze drumrum am besten unter
einem blatt paar so dass die pflanze
weiter nach oben wachsen kann ohne dass
dieser dieses seil ihrem weg ist und
dann kannst du sie daran immer wieder
fest binden wenn du mehr existieren
schon ein bisschen aufgewachsen ist und
wirklich wird damit sie nicht abbricht
weil das ist super schade wenn dieser
haupttriebfeder abbricht bei tomaten
dann hat man ein problem weil dann kann
sie nicht mehr weiterwachsen dann kann
man zwar noch einen guides trieb nach
oben leiten und den als zweiter
haupttriebfeder blieben aber das ist
immer ein bisschen umständlich und
nervig ist besser wenn du nicht
passieren tipp nummer 7 deine tomaten
brauchen einen absolut sonnigen platz
mindestens fünf stunden sonne sonst uns
gar nicht erst versuchen besser sind
sieben stunden und das ist super super
wichtig also such dir einen schönen
sonnigen ort für deine tomaten aus und
dann kommen wir auch schon zu tipp
nummer acht das bedeutet auf dem balkon
im topf oder im kübel baut man am besten
kleine flüchtige sorten wie zum beispiel
cherry oder cocktailtomaten an weil die
auch wenn es mal nicht so wenig ist oder
wenn der schatten auf den balkon fällt
immer noch gut früchte produzieren die
kommen mit den fünf stunden sonnenlicht
also ganz gut zurecht wohingegen große
fleischtomaten wie zum beispiel die
ananas tomate auf dem balkon nicht so
gute chancen hätten ihre früchte dann
auch ausreisen zu lassen wenn da nicht
den ganzen tag sonne drauf knallt und
wenn du deine pflanzen dann gepflanzt
hat dann kommt tipp nummer 9
du musst deine tomaten wenn du sie im
topf anbaus regelmäßig gießen die
regelmäßige feuchtigkeit oder
gleichbleibende feuchtigkeit ist bei
tomaten sowieso ganz wichtig und im topf
kann ganz viel gießwasser immer wieder
verdunsten das kann man kaum verhindern
und
deswegen ist es ganz wichtig dass du die
regelmäßig gießt manche leute sagen die
muss man nur einmal in der woche
schießen ich finde es aber zu sehen
nicht also die erde sollte nie komplett
austrocknen
deswegen ließen wir unsere tomaten wenn
wir daran denken jeden tag im topf wenn
es mal einen tag nicht klappt ist es
auch nicht dramatisch aber spätestens
alle drei tage soll in die ordentlich
gießwasser bekommen damit sie zufrieden
sind in ihrem topf weil er eben super
schnell austrocknet und dann kommt auch
schon tipp nummer 10 passend dazu dass
du deine tomaten ähnlich machen sollte
ist auch im topf ihr wisst ich bin ein
großer fan ich kann euch gerne noch mal
ein video hier um verlinken wo ich
erzähle wie viel arbeit uns milch in
unserem garten erspart
und das gilt genauso im topf gerade da
weil ich eben so schnell austrocknet es
ist super wichtig dass man die oberste
erdschicht mit einer organischen schicht
abdeckt wir benutzen dafür rasenschnitt
oder holzhackschnitzel da kannst du auch
strophe nehmen und das macht wirklich
einen enormen unterschied wenn es darum
geht dass der topf schön feucht bleibt
also auch topf nummer 1 richtig dick
mulchen da kann so ruhig 10 oder 15 cm
organisches material draufpacken das ist
gar kein problem
tipp nummer elf ich habe es euch
versprochen und sprechen wir noch mal
über die düngung wenn deine tomaten
angepflanzt sind da mach ich es so dass
ich entweder einen biologischen tomaten
dünner verwende es gibt ja tolle dinger
die genau auf tomaten abgestimmt sind da
kann ich euch auch gerne einen in wie
infobox packen ansonsten stehen tomaten
auch unglaublich auf brennessel ja die
stinkt ein bisschen kommt drauf an wie
man die so herstellt ob sie ganz
bestimmt oder nur ein bisschen
aber da freuen sich auch top tomaten
darüber muss man sich überlegen ob man
das auf den balkon machen will deswegen
ist ein biologischer tomaten den jahren
natürlich auch super league kann man ihm
dies wasser verdünnen und die tomaten
dann damit gießen und dann sind sie mit
allem versorgt was ich für ein
glückliches tomaten leben brauchen
damit kannst du dir dann alle drei
wochen dünnen entweder mit brennessel
auch oder mit einem biologischen tomaten
dünger auch mal beides abwechselnd ist
auch nicht schlecht da freuen sich an
einem roman drüber damit wünsche ich
euch eine dicke fette tomatenernte wenn
euch das video gefallen oder
weitergeholfen hat dann gebt ihm gerne
einen daumen nach oben
das hilft mir und meinem kanal ungemein
last auch gern ein
aber da wir haben noch viele andere
tomaten videos geplant dieses jahr wenn
ihr wissen wollt wie es weitergeht wie
man die zb aus geist oder wie man die
den sommer über pflegt dann tragt euch
gerne da unten ein es kommt auch
irgendwann sichern
tomaten so ist ein rezept zum einkochen
besitzt ja und teil das video gerne mit
deinen freunden wenn du freunde hast die
auch dieses jahr tomaten im topf anbauen
wollen und denen das video weiterhelfen
könnte dann würde ich mich supermarkt
darüber freuen da drüben findest du ein
video in dem ich die erzähle wie die
tomaten auch im freiland oder im
gewächshaus anbauen kannst und da unten
völlig ich dir auch ein video dass dich
interessieren könnte vielleicht sehen
wir uns ja da drüben wieder
bis dahin liegt gibt es nächste woche
macht es gut